Harry Styles is another singer whose
life is about to get the Hollywood TV
treatment well a tiny little chapter in
his life anyway in the new CBS sitcom
happy together so what does James Corden
have to do with it we were exclusively
concept I was working with one direction
a few years ago and Harry came to live
with us for a little while so now I
heard originally Harry was supposed to
move in for two weeks and he stayed for
a long time that long time was actually
20 months and Harry lived in Ben's attic
fast forward three years Ben became
James Corden's Late Late Show executive
producer which led to this and it also
led to this CBS's new sitcom happy
together loosely based on the time the
one Directioner shacked up with his
buddy and his wife
the paparazzi since its breakup and I
need a safe place to hide is it at all
possible that I crush it till it's all
dies down 20 year old Australian cutie
Felix Mallard plays Harry's character
Damon Wayans Jr and amber Stevens West's
take him in did Harry Styles personally
serenade you to get you on board for
this show it's our little secret
have you gotten advice from Harry on how
to deal with the fans no no you need to
ask it sir then we'll be doing double
duty on this show and Corden's and after
scoring big with Paul McCartney I just
had to ask who's next on the list
who's next I don't know I'd love Beyonce
to do it you know rolling stones would
be great
you
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]